hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 american science fantasy movie
called artemis fowl
the movie begins with a swarm of
reporters waiting outside foul manor
while reporting about the fowl who has
just been arrested for his criminal
activities
not long after an accomplice of artemis
fowl named mulch diggings is taken into
custody for helping foul the scene moves
to mi6 red ford interrogation facility
where mulch is being interrogated by the
authorities he reveals that he is just a
tunneler thus they should focus on
arresting the talented young boy artemis
fowl who is the brain of the operation
after that he tells them the full story
of fowls as well as a world of fairies
that they discovered artemis fowl is a
12 years old talented and genius boy who
lives in ireland it is revealed that
artemis managed to beat the european
chess champion win the architectural
competition and clone a goat in his
childhood
since he is a very genius boy he is
considered as different and doesn't get
along with his friends at school he has
to meet the school counselor who assumes
that artemis acts out due to his
mother's death or because of the burden
of his father's name artemis fowl senior
who is a renowned antique and rarities
dealer
feeling offended he walks out of the
room
artemis enjoys his father's companion
who likes to tell stories about fairies
goblins and other magical creatures
unfortunately artemis senior often
leaves his son alone due to his work
demands but this time he promises
artemis jr that his work is coming to an
end as he departs on his helicopter he
assures his son that he will keep him
safe
the next day the fowl's butler dome of
voy receives a call which tells him that
artemis senior has been kidnapped as the
boat arrived with no passenger inside it
meanwhile artemis wakes up and sees the
news on the tv accusing his father as a
notorious criminal mastermind who is
responsible for the disappearance of
several antiques and rarities all across
the world
dom immediately drags the sun from the
tv who still can't believe that the
media labels his father as a criminal
a few moments later artemis receives a
call from a mysterious figure called
opal kaboy she admits that she is the
one who kidnapped his dad and urges
artemis to obtain an artifact called the
aculos in three days or he will kill the
father left with no option don takes
artemis to an underground workspace of
his father and the generations before
him where he discovers a lot of weird
relics and notes about the fairies world
stored inside there based on the poem
artemis senior always reads before sleep
artemis manages to find his dad's
private journal at the last page of the
journal a writing states something about
a woman who threatens to kill him and
his colleague beechwood since she knows
that they keep the aculos which has to
be protected at all cost even from the
fairies themselves artemis starts to
believe that the fairies exist
the scene moves to the center of the
earth where haven city the home of the
fairies is actually real and not a fairy
tale it is still revealed that the
fairies are still struggling to find the
oculus turns out that mulch is a dwarf
and is sentenced to 400 years of hard
labor due to committing a number of
crimes
after that he meets up with official
holly short and asks her to help him out
but she refuses to do so
on the other side opel releases former
fairy commander brian cudjin from
custody and reinstates him to the
commander position while ordering him to
bring the aculos back to her before
artemis does commander root addresses
the issue about the missing aculos
stating that the artifact must be
recovered before it falls into the wrong
hands
officer holly then approaches the
commander asking permission to go to
hill of tara to investigate her father's
disappearance but root denies the
request she advises the officer not to
waste her life since she has a bright
future ahead
foley fairy tech genius suddenly spots
an unidentified troll on the surface
since all the field officers are
occupied commander root secretly orders
holly to go to the surface to identify
the creature
she is then ejected through a volcano by
using a capsule
brian who now acts as a mole for opal
questions the commander's decision since
holly is beechworth's daughter a traitor
who was accused of stealing the oculus
meanwhile on earth dom recruits his
niece juliet butler to assist artemis in
finding the oculus
after spending 12 hours of thorough
investigation artemis finds a leaded
hill of terror and plans to capture a
fairy that will be used to help him to
understand the fairy's world
holly flies to a party where she
encounters a giant troll who attempts to
eat a girl
she attacks the troll and saves the girl
although fairies aren't allowed to use
magic on humans holly disobeys the rule
and treats the girl's wound with magic
not long after a time freeze capsule is
deployed to prevent the troll from
eating the humans they get rid of the
troll and wipe the human's mind before
putting everything back to normal on her
way back holly takes a slight detour and
heads to hill of terra in an attempt to
clear her father's name
artemis continues reading his father's
journal learning that beechwood
deliberately handed over the aculos to
him to prevent the enemy opel from
gaining access to the fairy's strongest
spell
holly jumps into dom's trap and gets
captured
foley tracks holly's last location to
foul manor and the commander immediately
sends out every personnel to retrieve
holly before their identity is revealed
the next day holly awakens finding
himself locked up in a cage juliet and
artemis wear special glasses to prevent
the fairy from controlling their mind
artemis tries to negotiate with holly
but she threatens him saying that her
people will come to rescue her and
fairies don't negotiate a time freeze
capsule is deployed again while a horde
of ferry's army including commander root
arrive at foul manor artemis changes his
outfit and then shows up with dom
they are prepared and fight several
ferry soldiers with holly's weapon
dom manages to shoot the time freeze
capsule destabilizing the time freeze
root decides to make her way toward the
house to negotiate with artemis he
welcomes her offering to free holly in
exchange for the oculus
after the negotiation artemis talks to
holly who reveals that benchwood was her
father and their fathers worked together
to protect the aculos but benchwood was
framed as the traitor to the fairies
meanwhile opal reveals his plan to rule
both humans and fairies world with the
aculos since they are incapable of
friendship and coexistence
she adds that he will wipe out all of
mankind and restore fairies to their
rightful place
since the fairies are not allowed to
infiltrate the house commander root
decides to release mulch from custody
who likes to argue and fight with the
goblins whose skin is fire resistant in
the cell
mulch immediately gets transferred to
the surface
root offers to lighten his sentence if
mulch agrees to help her by digging his
way into the foul manner and retrieving
holly he agrees to the offer and
suddenly transforms into a big mouth
dwarf before digging into the house upon
arrival mulch whose eyes are installed
with a camera and x-ray scanner manages
to find the accolas hidden inside a safe
that is kept behind a picture of artemis
senior artemis somehow lets him open it
and retrieve the artifact as it is still
part of the plan while he finally
decides to release holly offering her to
work with him as soon as mulch opens the
safe artemis and holly confront him and
attempt to hide the aculos from the
fairies however they have seen it
through mulch's eye cajun immediately
informs opal about the discovery and she
orders him to intervene
he gathers the fairies army while
dismissing commander root from her duty
he then sends the captured huge troll
who is injected with a potion to make
him stronger and angrier to break into
the house
artemis teams up with dom juliet holly
and mulch to protect the aculos and
fight the enraged troll
mulch decides to swallow the oculus
where dom and the others attempt to
distract the monster
after a long and exhausting fight they
managed to trap the troll by tangling it
in a chandelier however the monster
falls down in the direction of artemis
but dom pushes him out causing him to be
hit by the troll's huge body instead
the captain orders his men to restore
holly's magic allowing him to revive dom
from his death
meanwhile the time freeze is collapsing
causing a lot of fairies to get thrown
around and forcing them to retreat from
foul manor the time freeze capsule
eventually explodes and everything goes
back to normal
realizing that her plan is falling apart
hobel decides to kill artemis sr with
the dark magic with the oculos in their
possession artemis urges holly to
activate its magic spell since no human
can wield it they officially become
friends and the officer manages to
create a portal to rescue artemis sr
from opel's hideout before getting
consumed by the dark magic
artemis finds his father waiting inside
his underground workspace where he
reveals to holly that her dad gave his
life to protect the oculus he then gives
a list of opal's accomplices to holly
hoping that she wants to investigate it
and capture them the officer brings the
aculos back to haven city where
commander root stores it inside a safe
place
she conducts an investigation to seek
out opel and her accomplices everyone in
the army congratulates holly for her
dedication and hard work
meanwhile artemis personally calls opal
threatening her that he will go after
her after that he and his dad depart
with a helicopter going to finish some
business
at this point mulch finishes his
investigation and still refuses to help
them apprehend artemis fowls
not long after he reveals that he is
actually a dwarf and has been swallowing
a tracking device allowing the fowls to
locate him and rescue him from the
facility they then fly away and are
ready for the new challenges ahead
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching